*music*
(shouts)
Is that the mic where you..
Yeah *laughs*
What the fuck man
Shut up!
- This is the professional ..
This is a Pewdiepie Video
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, are you the most subscribed..
I know, I can't even remember is that..
- You are at the Youtube Conference
You could've bought a shotgun for like 60 bucks
You keep throwing me these Dead serious death ???
Can you be nice for one second?!
No ;-;
Hey! How it's going? My name is PewDiePie!
I'm Markiplier..
I'm Jack- TOP OF THE MORNING TO YA LADIES!~
Was that good?
- No..
..and I'm also Markiplier..
*cricket sound*
*awkward silence*
Okayyy.... (laughs)
We're not here on this bed, just to fuck
That comes later
- That comes later..
bring it in
Okay
CLAP :D
Cool
-lalalalalalalalalalalala
ow fuck
were gonna play this game, loser gets shocked and has to eat a soggy biscuit.
raise the stakes on this one
every time I've played this, I've lost.
good!
frick
these guys didn't even tell me what we were -
Dont worry about it just grab it
okay
just grab it and close your eyes
do i have to hold down the button orr?
YES!
yeah hold down the button
Laughing xD
my hand is tingling already
Oh god, I don't want to *laughing*
from the memories of this thing
oh fuck meee
*weird noises*
i think i'll make it -
* manly screaming*
WHAT DA FUCKK
*still screaming* WHY DOES EVERYONE GET BURNED?? - I didn't. (shut up Jack)
*laughing* So it's- oh. So your sweeping strike
did you cut me!?!
oh my god!
WHAT THE FUCK
*more laughing*
AHHHHHhh
*screaming*
yaaay :)
Yaaaaaay!
Heuehuehueheuhhe
NOO!
T-that camera is so on the wonk it's - (pewds changed his shirt xD)
DON'T WORRY 'BOUT IT
*Laughing*
An hour into getting to New York and like i like
got a haircut like I'm feeling my look and he just runs up and goes
WKSHHHHHHHHHHHAAAA
*everyone's laughing*
and this is a, this is like a, like this is a... i'm disfigured
I'm a
Do not put makeup on my open wound you motherfuck
Is that toothpaste? - It's gonna burn
Also, we discovered that is a fuck button
That is, um. Try the fuck button.
*Funky music* Straight up and fuck the ball
*Singing?* Yeahhh
Aw shit
I'm not- AH MOTHERFUCKING. YOU -
*Keep laughing, Jack. Keep laughing.*
WHAT THE FUCK, MAN?
C'mon
*There it is. The manly screams*
*More manly screaming.* I don't like it
You love it.
I- I don't like it
Let's do elimination. We're switching-
But I- I just want to win. I know how you feel now.
OK, we go hand, to neck, to balls, to butt hole.
To teeth
Awww, I don't want to do the butt hole (That's what she said)
*Victorious screaming mixed with cries of pain and defeat*
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?! ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
*Markimoo throws tantrum*
Oh, I'm done.
I'll hold it.
Thanks, man. You really care about - *Mark scoffs*
*More revelries as those who win move on, and those who lose, die.*
NO! WHY'D I TRY TO PICK IT UP AGAIN
No more testicles for me *realizes his mistake*
YOU'RE GOING DOWNTOWN BITCH
I just wanted to be loved. Alright, I'm sorry I play video games!
Grab it. Grab it! *don't take that out of context*
I'm fucking
Scared?
Yeah! I am actually scared!
*SURPRISE*
*SURPRISE AGAIN*    *Screams of pain*
Oh, that felt so good (sure it did)
*Laughs at other peoples pain*
I tried so hard.
Oh, that's a good shot. Ohhhhh
You have to press that button. I don't WANT to press the button.
Press the f-ing button
I don't wanna.
DO IT
ooooo.
Oh
Oh *Bystanders laugh at the situation*
What's happening?
Wait. If I tase my-
DO IT NOW
no
YESSSS
*THE SOUND OF PAIN*
*AND THEN LAUGHTER CAUSE PEWDS IS SPAZZING OUT*
JESUS CHRIST
aH
I love it
Oh, that reaction was everything I hoped it would be
*Pewds tries to shock innocent bystander and fails*
My balls fucking hurt, man.
Yeah, it's an ache for a while. It really hurts
*JACK-A-BOY'S TURN*
*FEEL THE BURN*
*Damn pewdiepie.*
*MARKIMOO'S TURN*
*That looks painful*
*and a bunch of bad decisions*
Hit the plug button
*Exasperated Markimoo sigh*
Ah, my balls dude